anyway I'm going to talk about uh some
of the capturing and the utilization of
the nutrients and I'm going to talk
about it a lot from the standpoint of
people that have moved from open feed
lots to these types of facilities some
of the things that are different some of
the
considerations that you need to make
that are are going to make
things some of the big differences um
with an open feed lot you can uh do
chores probably once every six months as
far as scraping and cleaning out the
barns or cleaning out the pens and so
forth it needs to be very timely in
these barns um so it becomes part of
weekly chores uh also you are in close
proximity with the c um when you're
moving moving in there with equipment
and I take it nobody wants to scrape
these barns by hand right okay you're
going to be in there with the cattle um
different cattle are going to behave
differently but often times they become
more and more accustomed to the uh
tractors the equipment in there and
there's a
tendency to bump them especially late
late in the uh feeding period when
you've got all the money and so forth in
and uh you got to be very very careful
and think about what you're doing think
about the way you design these so that
you can clean out the manure on a
regular basis and not injure the cattle
especially when they're ready to go on
the truck tomorrow as far as the
nutrients that are out
there I guess I'm going to think about
them in terms of where they're coming
from and we have the two different types
we've got the the part that's coming out
of the urine um which is going to be
mostly all our potassium very soluble in
the open lots a lot of times that is
lost through run off that comes off the
top we're going to be able to cap
capture that it does attach quickly to
exchange sight so some of the soil and
so forth under an open lot will have it
otherwise we're going to be capturing
that with our bedding ammonia and we've
done the study it can but volatilize and
often times if you're losing very much
ammonia from just your standpoint you
can smell if you can smell it a lot that
probably means that we've got it leaving
it also will attach to the exchange
sites on things um cattle produce a lot
of species or the organic matter that
Parts probably always or very often
going to be all captured in our uh
facilities that's the part that takes
some additional breakdown in order for
our plants to use
it and it actually contains lots of
exchange sites and so if you've got a a
piece of property that you've applied
manure on year after year often times
you'll you'll see that it's able to
retain more it has a higher organic
matter in it that's because that's where
it came from
we take a look at at how much the
animals produce versus how much we're
able to capture in the different systems
um reason why in the beded
barns we're probably going to be adding
around a baale 1,00 to 1200 lb of
additional material out there to soak up
that urine uh keep things dry and that's
why we have a a higher amount here in
terms of the capture versus the open
lot uh on a a deep
pit um we put things down here and this
is I get a lot of people asking me when
they've done some manure
analysis why do you have so much more
captured from a deep pit and it's really
just a matter of how we Mar measure it
okay this is measured in pound per th000
gallons there
is in 1,000 gallons there are 4 tons of
material so these are actually going to
be roughly speaking four times as great
as this because of the difference in the
way that we're actually
measuring when people are building um
livestock facilities for cattle um one
of the
thing salesman often talk about the cost
per head
space on their facilities yes I'd like
you to take a look at it in terms of
cost per square foot so that you can
evaluate all of these on I'll say the
same basis is and also when we move
cattle into facilities the facilities
are relatively speaking
expensive and so we squeeze more animals
into less
space
um we're normally down in in the lower
end of this I'll say at least uh uh 40
square ft per head at 40 square ft per
head the amount of urine that you get on
a daily basis is a/4 inch
okay that's with little
C that is as much as we get in terms of
evaporation on the warm day so a lot of
times we're going to have them in here
dense enough that you're going to keep
everything wet I put this into the paper
and it's also up here at the various
stocking densities how much depth of a
manure do you get in a week and think
then about how free frequently you're
going to scrape and get that cleaned up
okay and over time U that I've been with
Iowa State University extension service
we move from finished cattle that were
900 to 1,000 head now I I see
14500 lb cattle routinely being that big
before they're going to Market when
they're that big they produce a lot more
manure we've done some things in terms
of feeding so that we can still put on
muscle on those uh big animals but
they're eating a lot of feed they're
gaining a lot of weight and they're
producing a lot of manure if they're in
tight tight uh positions we're looking
at a lot of manure being produced at
large cattle we're looking at over 5 in
per
week okay and if you have a cleaning
schedule that's on here the difference
between The Big C cattle and the little
cattle and at the end of the feeding
period you need to be on it on on your
schedule or adjust your schedule so you
you can be on it because being one or
two days late is the difference between
having cattle that clean and nice and
are able to keep their hair coat and
those that
aren't this is uh why we use the bedding
help soak up the manure keep the cattle
clean
okay change the uh manure from a semi or
slurry into a semisolid that we're able
to handle something that's at least uh
80% water that sounds like a lot right
20% solids 80% water that will stand up
nicely in a manure sprad okay if it gets
higher than that it runs out the back
gate um what are the cons considerations
of course betting has cost involved with
it and it's gotten higher over time and
especially in years when you have a late
wet season when you need betting the
most it's going to be the hardest to
make and if you can't make it nobody
else did and it's going to be very
expensive so just put that on your your
thing every time you handle it it costs
more money storing it costs some money
and of course processing helps to
improve the surface area so you can soak
that stuff the urine up quickly but of
course that costs more money uh where do
you want to store it uh of course you
want to often times have it very close
to the bar um and you'd like to keep it
high and dry so that you have as Le the
least amount of sto spoilage as
possible and here we've got it high and
dry now uh with uh with these if you are
slow and late or also I'll say you you
got to make sure that you evaluate how
good the quality is of the beding
especially late in the year when we've
had some de decomposition of it you
might need to add a few Bales so we
don't end up with a with a cattle that
have lost their hair coat they lose the
hair coat and they're also going to have
to use more of their the feed to control
their body temperature especially when
it gets
cold Bing is going to change with the
season and uh with cattle at least a lot
of the individuals I'm working with
we're feeding uh Cals Cavs in the fall
maybe yearlings uh to get another turn
through there uh when we bring them in
in the fall dealing with the smaller
cabs probably start them out on a a
little bit uh less hot diet in terms of
nutrients and so forth um it's normally
dry um the betting is the highest
quality we're going to have each year so
that we're probably going to start out
with using utilizing the least amount at
that time as winter goes on hopefully
the Cals are growing the quality of
bending still good we will have the the
occasional snow storms that come through
and big openings on our buildings will
allow U some of that to come in need to
adjust and in increase the amount of
bedding when that happens uh
spring we're dealing now with bigger
cattle normally if we have some uh rain
or so forth the bedding is going to be
wet so part of its usefulness has
already been used up we have that thaw
period and high humidity so we're not
going to get the the
evaporation and we do get the frequent
rains so again we're going to have to
adjust our Bing
upward now uh the last one is Summer and
I put this on here for the people that
have changed from a open feed lot to a
beded barn they tell me that the biggest
thing that was a aha moment in in terms
of it is you use more bedding in the
summer than you did the fall and winter
which is the exact opposite if you beded
in an open lot you beded during the
winter but you never did anything during
the summer with these facilities to keep
things moving one you've got great big
cattle you've got hot conditions the
cattle are drinking more some of the uh
feed ingredients we have may contain
some additional sodium some additional
things that cause the animals to drink
more more drinking is going to produce
more urine needs to be soaked up and
often at the very end of the feeding
period we're dealing with deterior
deteriorated bedding it's pretty much
used up so they'll often times use 50%
more bedding in the summer than they do
in the winter and did not expect that to
be um when they started out with the
facility uh deep
pits um they're going to be under the
the
slots um when you look at back to where
we were in terms of how much manure
you're producing if you have a 8 to 10t
pit you're going to have to pump that
out twice a year in order to have the
storage that you need to keep the cattle
in there uh and I don't see anybody
that's putting in a deep enough pit to
make it through one year so you're going
to plan on doing that it will tend to be
more
consistent and you're going to be able
to capture that and put that
through when you think about building
the building with something that you're
going to be in there at least weekly
probably bi-weekly to uh clean okay and
often times with the cattle in there we
need to make sure that we've got curbs
so we can scrape along the edges make it
easy to get done uh push walls for
loading up that manure maybe where we're
going to place our Manure Spreader so we
can put that all together um and then
also maybe some extra mirrors on the
thing so you can monitor where that
cattle are often times we move moving
forward slamming the uh tractor into
reverse after we've load it up a load
and often times We're Not Looking Back
where those cattle as they especially
get accustomed to the equipment might be
very very close to you and end up
bumping
them uh here's a push wall um and I when
I talk about push walls this is going to
be a reinforced concrete wall
that you can push the loader into it and
not worry about breaking anything okay
and when you think about uh the
equipment that you're going to use for
uh for building since these buildings
are going to last what 30 40
years look at the equipment that you
would like to own not the equipment that
you now have cuz it how many of you guys
want to buy a small smaller
Tractor No
Hands oh there's a couple hands somebody
wants one anyway so make sure you you
reinforce it so that you you won't have
the problems and think about the
individual you might hire that doesn't
have any experience with the tractor
that might hit the the top of the push
wall uh when he slips the his foot off
the clutch
uh here's here is a nice curb along this
Edge and you will be moving back and
forth along there and think about
especially when you get down into the
really tight ones where there's enough
room for the cattle to get back away
from
it Angie if you guys want to know how
big that is Angie right there is our as
our marker um as far as storage inside
the building versus out inside the
building of course it's going to be
expensive but it's very convenient um to
have some storage inside the building
we're probably not going to put it very
much there but uh having a couple weeks
is uh nice uh it's under roof it's also
going to be in a place where you're
going to capture everything um can also
put it just outside nice uh push walls
here also can contain it makes it
convenient so you can get the job done
even when the weather conditions are
poor outside and you need to have be
able to do this in all weather
conditions with
bars okay if we move that off site and
uh often times we'll have both but move
it away from the barn uh to the field
where it's going to be utilized uh it is
a second place to manage uh and may be
regulations and Community standards and
I'll just say I get calls each year
somebody says they don't want to smell
it next to their house so they moved it
out to the field where I'm at um and
even if it doesn't quote unquote breed
flies it will attract flies and all I
say is don't put it in front of the
person's
house and we've had that happen before
but it does help it normally the uh
Fields adjacent to our facilities have
high nutrient contents those fields that
are out a long ways away could really
use the p and the K that we are able to
capture
from um managing it make sure that we're
not losing it to the
ground uh keep it high and
dry
um do not stockpile it and grab
Waterway and minimize the time that it's
out there where we can have losses